herzlich willkommen ich bin heute in
rüsselsheim im globus-markt hier ist am
samstag eine autogrammstunde und ich hab
gedacht ich komm' vorab schon mal her
und schaue mit den neuen großmacht der
globus-markt hat seit kurzem eröffneten
hat über 300 arbeitsplätze geschaffen
und für nächstes jahr bis mitte des
jahrzehnts oder 500 wenn man den ganzen
umkreis hier auch verachtet und ich
werde jetzt gleich in den großmarkt
reingehen und einfach mal schauen was es
da so gibt der jodel sally hay sally ist
zeige ihnen ist ehre ihnen wie's
funktioniert
okay aber das übernehme ich heute mittag
l and ypsilon also kommt mit dann hole
ich jetzt mal bei der rallye einen
genauen zeitrahmen dann muss ich damit
machen
meinen einkauf staat ich jetzt hier in
der obstabteilung ein paar mandarinen
mit und ich hoffe das gerne
das heißt das hier ist mein scanner und
ich brauch später nicht an die kasse zu
gehen sondern ich kann selber bezahlen
und ich habe hier zwei tüten gleich
besorgt dann kann ich nämlich auch den
einkauf gleich reinräumen und bin viel
schneller fertig die mandarinen gäste
abwägen
der vorteil ist natürlich kann die
gleich später die papiertragetasche
machen brauche ich keine extra töte euch
kann ich hier die nummer auswählen und
nach vorne ablesen andere stationen
jetzt habe ich schon mein etikett lebe
ich jetzt mal drauf dann kommen sie
schon in die tüte und natürlich
abstellen nicht vergessen
oma da kann man die meisten bäckereien
reinschauen und kann sehen wie sie hier
die ware produzieren
ich glaube das wird mal so eine
kitchenette sich mit zuhause anschaffen
muss
definition bäckerei terminal und bar
kann man hier die produkte checken die
man gerne kaufen möchte ich habe zum
beispiel das dinkelvollkornbrot nehmen
wir zu hause immer ganz gerne aber wenn
man sich informieren möchte was drin
steckt geht man hierher und kann das
hier eingeben und dann einfach der
inhaltsstoff anschauen
wir stehen dann die zutaten und es steht
auch drin waren eben nicht drin ist das
heißt ohne ohne nüsse ohne soja zum
beispiel die ganzen allergenen stoffe
und man kann auch das produkt bewerten
und da ich das produkt kenne wenn man
möchte kann man sogar den erweiterten
und die produkte vergleichen
da kommt man nicht an die linken
was markus steht 40 in der produktion
hier mit gerate baumkuchen gemacht und
bei baumkuchen muss ich echt sagen kann
ich nicht nein sagen
also muss ich mir gleich meine
produktion anschauen und hinter mir
steht am martinez konditor und
bäckermeister und ja produziert es hier
alles von hand und jetzt gucken einfach
mal rein und ich zeige euch wie man
warum gucken
wir dürfen sie auch da ich den baum
kuchen probieren und anbauen guten liebe
ich es da sind diese einzelnen schichten
zu sehen 12 bis 14 stück macht
approbation und gibt anderen
verschiedenen sorten und ich habe jetzt
einfach nur jedem 1 eingepackt
die abteilung finde ich total genial
denn man kann hier im gesamten globus
markt verschiedene artikel auch ohne
verpackung kaufen das spart natürlich
geld und natürlich die umwelt saniert
und hier nimmt man sich mit hütte raus
und jetzt möchte ich mir ein bisschen
mitleid mitnehmen und demnächst gibt's
noch mehrwegverpackungen das heißt jetzt
brauche ich schon noch die papiertüte
aber die service michael baar
und das nächste mal wenn ich komme
gibt's dann schon die mehrweg
verpackungen die ich eben öfter benutzen
kann es kompliziert runter und dann kann
ich mir die beliebige menge hieraus
lassen
jetzt kann ich schon bezahlen gehen
hallo
ein kopf beenden
den einkauf der löwen haben den scanner
zurückgegeben und mit der karte kann ich
jetzt bezahlen und ich finde es ganz
toll dass man die ganze zeit auf dem
scanner ablesen konnte wie viel geld man
eben schon im warenkorb drin hat das
heißt man hat die kontrolle kosten
kontrolle und weiß eben wenn ich nur 25
euro hat zum einkaufen dann weiß ich
welcher punkt erreicht das nicht eben
einkaufen sollte jetzt kommt die kraft
muss ich auch abscannen
hier sind meine kassenzettel ok einkauf
bezahlen
hier kann man robert und leergutbons
gutscheine und so weiter auch einlösen
man kann ihr bar oder mit karte zahlen
was ich ziemlich cool findet denn so
kann jeder diese gerne benutzen
jetzt habe ich bezahlt jetzt können wir
nach vorne gehen ins restaurant denke
wir haben ziemlich hunger
wo ich bin ist mit dem einkauf fertig
und ich wollte ich nur mal an die
autogrammstunde erinnern und reißt die
tür am samstag von 15 bis 17 uhr
natürlich bleiben wir längerer wenn ganz
viele leute da sind ich freue mich
natürlich auf jeden einzelnen
und es wird auch während der wartezeit
für euch gesorgt das heißt es gibt
getränke und auch was zu essen und ich
freue mich über jeden einzelnen der
vorbeikommt und schaut euch auf jeden
fall den globus markt vorher an falls
ihr es seid nicht schafft und wir gehen
jetzt im restaurant noch essenzen und
freunde gesandt sagte falk